need an incentive to pedal faster well
over in South Africa these cycling
buddies accidentally found a great one
it's behind you is he trying to attack
them or race them
Olek miss Janko and his friends
certainly ruffled a few feathers but are
they in danger understandably these guys
were terrified ostriches strong legs can
provide quite a powerful kick enough to
break a human's back in addition they
have extremely long and powerful claws
that can inflict some serious wounds now
in this case Ola and his friends weren't
in any danger because if the ostrich
wanted to catch them it could have in
fact the ostrich could have passed them
ostriches can run 40 miles per hour or
65 kilometers per hour so how can a
stray jiz reach such great speeds
instead of running on their entire foot
ostriches are actually running on two
toes running on their toes gives
ostriches a longer stride and in
addition their leg anatomy allows them
to be really efficient runners using
tendons in their legs and feet so why is
the ostrich so interested in the
cyclists it actually appears that the
ostrich was confused by the cyclists and
maybe even a little afraid and he's
suffering from what's known as caught in
traffic this is a phenomenon where
animals end up following a flow of
people or vehicles because they're
frightened and they can't see a safe way
to exit this epic road runner finally
pulls over and pedal power wins the day